Round 423,275 to the
nearest thousand.
So let me rewrite it: 423,275.
And so the thousands place is
the 3 right here, and so if we
were round it up to the nearest
thousand, we would go
to 420-- let me write it so we
just focus on the 3-- we would
go up to 424,000 if we wanted
to round up, 424,000, and if
we wanted to round down,
we would go to 423,000.
We would get rid of the 275.
423,000.
So this is our choice.
Round up to 424,000 or round
down to 423,000.
And to figure it out, we just
look at the digit one place to
the right of the 3, so we look
at the 2 right there.
If that digit is 5 or greater,
you round up.
So this is 5.
So if this is greater than
or equal to 5, 5 or
greater, you round up.
If it's less than 5,
you round down.
2 is definitely less than 5, so
we just round down, so it
is 423,000.
Now just to visualize what
this means to the nearest
thousand, if I were to do a
number line-- and you don't
have to do this.
We've gotten the answer, but
just to have a little bit
better visualization of it,
if I were to increment by
thousands, you might have
422,000, 423,000.
You have 424,000, and then
maybe over here, you have
425,000, and you could
keep going.
Now 423,275 is going to be
someplace right around here.
And so when we round to the
nearest thousand, we have to
pick between that and that.
We see that it much closer to
423,000 than to 424,000, so we
round it right there.
But you just use the rules we
just came up with, and we
rounded down to 423,000.